hier soir tf1 diffusait la traque un
téléfilm d'yves rénier qui retrace les
douze mois d'interrogatoires de michel
fourniret suspecté de plusieurs viols et
meurtres sur des jeunes filles mineures
je n'accepte pas ce qui s'est passé un
téléfilm beaucoup décrié avant sa
diffusion car il mettra en lumière
l'histoire d'un monstre qui repose
actuellement en prison
selim fournirait son fils avait
d'ailleurs tenté de faire stopper la
production voir un film qui va sortir
comme ça selon que tu as tué mon fils
j'imagine sans à saint-vit 20 mai tf1
s'était justifié en expliquant vouloir
montrer le travail acharné des
enquêteurs
interprété par françois xavier demaison
et mélanie bernier sur cette affaire
c'est lui l aide
je le sais philippe torreton qui se
glissait dans le rôle de michel
fourniret avec une ressemblance
époustouflant d' avait quant à lui
défendu la fonction éducative de ce
téléfilm je le regardais avec mes
enfants qui en appelle aux 9 et 12 10
ans sont arrivés à la conclusion qu'un
adulte n'a pas le droit d'adresser la
parole un enfant dans la rue avec 4,8
millions téléspectateurs ce téléfilm
semble avoir conquis le public sur la
forme mais sur le fond tf1 at-elle
réussi son adaptation de la sphère
fourniret alors acquis c'est une vraie
réussite je suis scotché
je découvre l histoire très bien réalisé
aussi à des longues elissa est-ce qu'on
a un peu déçu par le score déjà les plus
chauds le score énorme par rapport à
toutes les conseillers ici c'est à dire
que c'est c'est très dur à regarder pour
les familles c'est terrible moi je ne
comprends toujours pas le succès je
trouve que c'est un vrai succès quatre
millions et demi non mais ils auraient
dû faire cette liste
c'est une histoire est extrêmement
compliquée en face et mes énormes et
c'était leur truc de compliquer regarder
honnêtement j'ai pas trouvé téléfilm
mauvais maintenant on voit qu'il a
dérangé énormément de monde il a dérangé
le fils de michel fourniret il l'a dit
sur ce plateau il a dérangé le famille
d' les les familles des victimes puisque
le père d'estelle mouzin a dit qu'il
était choqué par à part ce film et
certains téléspectateurs il ya plein de
tweets en disant que les téléspectateurs
étaient choqués et je pense que tf1 le
paye en audience quand ils font
jacqueline sauvage et font 8 milliards
mais c'est pour ces attendait au moins
six millions et demi
holy pourrissant torhout avec mercy
journaliste co auteur du fils de locre
avec ses livres on irait vous étiez venu
nous voir alors ça y est il a été
diffusé ce téléfilm déçu ou pas vous
le seul journaliste à avoir interviewé
michel fournir aux reds d'ailleurs je
peux vous dire que le fournirait qu'on a
que nous a survendu faux tf1 hier soir
et c'est absolument pas le vrai fournir
et je vais rencontrer quoi c'est à dire
tout la réalité c'est-à-dire et michel
onfray une réelle n'a pas eu là on en a
eu la preuve
mais on sait que c'est une passe et une
parodie quoi la réalité elle arrive très
bientôt dans une revue laquelle karl
zéro qui s'appelle roland l'envers des
l'envers des affaires liées à la vérité
l'année promet début avril
tout est faux il ya ces c'est encore une
fois c'est un antique des fictions
adapté d'un roman où on nous sur vend
quoi des flics qui aurait bien fait leur
la ccpo fournir il est connu depuis 1966
pour des faits de pédophilie
il a eu devant lui le champ libre des
décennies d'impunité et là on est sur
des flics où l'on ferme ida on le dit
c'est une insulte pour tout ce qui s'est
passé pour les additifs dont on n'a pas
encore découvert ne serait-ce que
l'existence elle reliera les prix
surtout au juste qu'est ce qu'il a
qu'est ce qu'il ya de différent
michel fourniret dans la vraie vie le
soir on a vu hier dans le téléfilm a par
exemple on voit michel fourniret dans
une grotte en train de prier la vierge
marie
michel fourniret de même pas catholique
ça c'est quoi signe encore une façon de
frapper sur l'église de tirer sur
l'ambulance il n'est pas catholique du
tout vous les innus yahoo
oui j'ai vu la scène où on voit
fournirait dents de devant c'est une
thèse qui est survendu depuis de
nombreux mois la vierge marie avec eux
fournir en train de devant la vieille
marotte mais non mais ça c est ce qu a
connues psy on être aussi le début du
film
alors dites moi ça commence comment
alors le film avec justement ça commence
avec céline qui ouvre la porte à la
police venue arrêter son panier céline
n'était pas présent non vous avez rien
si je vous dis je vous parle de cette
sage c'est le début c'est le début comme
en série b to c n'est même pas présent
au domicile de ce jour là et enfin le
problème c'est que les gens
hier soir ont eu l'illusion de
s'inscrire sur une affaire toujours en
cours d'instruction sur la base de vent
c'est pas la faire fournir et là j'ai vu
les ré les réactions sur les réseaux à
les flics ils ont fait un boulot
formidable mais c'est même pas vrai les
deux enquêteurs qui sont mis en scène
dans cette fiction n'existe même pas ah
oui mais ça
aujourd'hui tout le monde a un avis
tranché tout le monde a un avis tranché
sur la paire fourniret ils ont utilisé
un couple d'enquêteurs fictifs qui
permettait justement de montrer qu'il
s'agissait qu'on mettait un petit peu à
distance et qu'il s'agissait d'un récit
fictionnel par rapport à une sur la base
d'une histoire et d'un goût de mon
départ est par ailleurs moi je trouve
que c'est plutôt réussi parce
qu'effectivement d'abord il n'y a aucun
moment où on voit des choses qui
pourraient heurter stade il n'y a pas de
tortures les noms des victimes ont
heureusement été changée et échanger
vous êtes à niort 4 millions et demi
c'est un peu des fils aux traders pour
revenir les objets et il est le ils
n'ont pas dit qu'ils allaient faire une
église est sur une l'histoire en
question sur le fait divers
alors pourquoi avoir gardé les noms de
michel fourniret et monique olivier
n'importe quoi gilbert des je trouve que
sa valise des faits divers à lui de
garder valérie vous tombez dans le piège
moi j'ai trouvé ça d'abord mauvais ce
qui peut expliquer le score c'est que
c'était lénifiant que sectoriel perdant
comme bébé mâle faye avait pas moyen
et j'ai trouvé ça honteux je suis très
en colère parce que c'est pas vrai que
c'est une fiction
je sens quand on voit quand on voit
monique olivier cayla personnage
principal du film la femme l'ex femme de
mick ferait exactement éplorée je vous
signale les je vous signale humanise
jallet et humaniser presque un couple
héroïsé presque une histoire d'amour
elle a été condamnée à 2008
en 2008 à la perpétuité avec 28 ans de
sûreté et elle devient l'héroïne et
c'est une honte ce qui s'est passé alors
nettement dans le tennessee
excuse moi c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
vu ben non pas du tout j'ai vu
entièrement excuse moi j'ai vu
entièrement effectivement tu peux pas
nier même si c'est un monstre et l'un et
l'autre c'est une histoire d'amour avant
tout évidemment je sais tout et c'est de
proposer 12 heures
ils ont laissé que des mangas rakim on
voit ça jacqueline sauvage à des fils
est dit et bien sûr les mêmes faits mais
ça fait dur et de construction tel
symbole d'un échec retentissant
je veux dire on parle d'un violeur
d'enfant mais attendait justement
sèchement compliqué à regarder mais
c'est pour ça que c'est déjà compliqué
pour les gens de regarder le truc
d'ailleurs vous le voyez bien sûr les
scores des femmes responsables des
achats ou les 25 49
vous avez vu que les mariés sont même
devant sur ces cibles nature c'est
qu'ils arrivent à l'ajustement des
socios ça a été un déferlement de 2e
ronde comment on donne larmes en donnant
pas du tout m'a donné autant de
visibilité restait le finir il est un
passeur du pouvoir pour adapter votre
roman vous auriez accepté pour tester
ces deux choses différentes noble la
maison la maison j'ai l'ogresse c'est
une fiction ailleurs c'est écrit en
préambule
ça n'arrête dans le fils de look c'est
la réalité une réalité car il dérangeait
beaucoup de monde parce que voulez-vous
qu la mère d un enfant je ne sorte pas
j'ai reçu des pressions de menaces
d'ailleurs grâce au téléfilm selim
fournirait reçu des menaces de mort hier
soir oui parce qu'ils ont les gens
comprennent rien à rien de michel
fourniret compris pense que c'est l'imf
défendez ses parents non non c'est pas
du tout ça au nom même loquace et l'on
s'était positionné du côté des victimes
et il n'a pas été répondu tout comme la
maman d'elisabeth briché le papa
d'estelle mouzin
voilà ils n'ont pas été respectées et
c'est très plaisant pas traiter cette
affaire là d'ailleurs on a une pensée
pour les victimes va nous parler du
l'année 2003-2004 et sam utah c'était
beaucoup plus tard pourquoi ne pas
reverser une partie des bénéfices aux
familles de la team est parti c'est ce
que c'est l'imam ali s'est pas vendu
c'est dommage mais je demande si la
reverser une partie des dividendes de
son lui je peux gagner je peux gagner
des milles mais il s'est pas vendue mais
vous l'avez proposer toute façon des
mérites en desservant son livre bernard
il est très bon je me dis moi j'ai pas
lu pouvait pas juger pas dit que je les
lui il n'y a pas eu
j'ai pas dit que je les lui je dis
simplement qu'il a proposé son livre
avant à des producteurs gens favorisés
n'en sait jamais de la vie
tf1 nous a approchés à travers des
producteurs fin 2018 on m'a dit non
donc si monsieur le commissaire avait
dit pourquoi prenez sénile qui racontent
n'importe quoi
est ce que si avec yves rénier je sais
je sais oui mais faut pas tenter renier
pourquoi vous dit ce n'est pas insulter
vous allez dire qu'il est sénile baisse
il raconté des choses qui sont fausses
et de l'armée raconte pas ça il fera
chaud de saint-adrien non non il n'a pas
tenté d'empêcher vous pas chez vous
c'est lé spectateur s'il vous plaît oui
à 41% non à 59%